what was difficult in the early days
early time Voodoo and what did you have
to personally learn or do to get the
company through that over the past 20
years I think I've had eight years close
to bankruptcy so the difficulty has
always been the cash because we
bootstrap the company I didn't raise a
lot of money I raised my first round
when I when I was 100 employees so it
was very hard to to develop the software
and serve the client at the same time to
get the money and so it was all about
working hard long days and surviving
sometimes we were doing a project that
aware not a profitable just for the just
for the cash but by doing that we always
did it with a vision we always had this
vision of making Enterprise management
software business applications asked for
the world and accessible to SMS so even
though we we didn't went straight and we
had to do things just because we had to
survive we always thought about this
video that we have today which is a good
integrated management software and
affordable